hey youtubers is Charlie so I just
posted a flash video about the road
ahead and what's gonna be happening with
some of the characters on that show so
I'm gonna do the same thing for arrow
I'll be talking about some of the big
arcs that are gonna be happening in the
back half of the season we already know
about the big Black Canary art some
people are calling the next three
episodes the canary trilogy and Oliver
has this really big flashback storyline
that they're gonna be teeing up and yes
you know even though the DC movies and
the TV shows are officially separate
universes at least on paper I do think
the Suicide Squad movie happening so
soon is gonna have some influence on the
way the show can use the Suicide Squad
characters but I'll explain what I mean
let's talk about Oliver first because I
know that's what everyone's really going
crazy about when we last saw him he was
very clearly at the point of death so
just as a way to sidestep his recovery
be it through use of Lazarus Pit or more
traditional means Stephen Amell just
can't totally check out of the show for
four or five episodes so that's why
they're teeing up a big flashback
storyline he's been posting a crazy
number of pictures to social media that
featured him with the classic flashback
wig on there's also one of him with
Robbie Amell too that's really confusing
I don't think that firestorm is going
back in time or anything like that I
just think Robbie Amell happened to be
visiting the set that day although yes I
do think that some day in the future
firestorm will totally cross over to
arrow so as of the end of episode 9
there were a couple big WTFs that they
teed up that they're gonna have to pay
off in episode 10 most notably China
white taking messiahs wife and the giant
bio weapon so the big goal the
flashbacks are gonna be to fix those two
problems although that might take the
entire rest of the season this is where
it gets a little weird because when
Oliver first recognized Masayo in the
League of Assassins it seemed like he
was really pissed like he had left his
identity as Masayo behind because
something really tragic happened that's
why I think that his wife and child are
dead or China white kills them or they
die eventually I've also talked about it
before but messiahs wife is actually
katana in the comics but I think what
they might have done is just give the
katana persona to Masayo part of her
origin story is tied up in this really
tragic event let's just say bad things
happen to her family so she takes on a
superhero persona that's why I think
that Messiah joined the league so that's
our jumping-off point and we do have
some details about what's happening
between episodes 10 and episode 15
Stephen Amell actually said this really
cool thing
he said that in the back half of the
season and this is true for season two
as well every four or five episodes is
its own self-contained art so there's
gonna be like two even three big arcs in
the back half of the season it was
really interesting he talked about the
first ten episodes as this single arc
and then the back half of the season
there being a couple of really small
arcs so let's start with episode 10
that's called Left Behind episode 11 is
called midnight City episode 12 is
called uprising episode 13 is called
Canaries episode 14 is the return in
episode 15 is Nanda Parbat I know that
last one's gonna get everyone really
excited so for most of this stuff I'm
just gonna be focusing on the new comic
book characters that they've announced
as well as the Black Canary in the
flashback arcs so this is all based on
stuff that the producers have said
publicly but just in case you guys don't
want to know potential spoiler warning
for episodes that are coming up so here
we go number 10 left behind mostly a
reference to team arrow like all the
people all of our leaves behind this is
also like a big Christian novel series
about what happens to the survivors
after most of the world gets raptured
take this as meaning like Oliver has
been raptured and now team arrow has to
figure out what the hell to do while
he's away although we know Oliver's not
dead if we do see Hong Kong flashback
scenes
it'll just be to tee up what Masayo and
Oliver are gonna do with Amanda Waller
to fix all their problems I think it's
mostly going to focus on the modern-day
team arrow storyline I'm actually really
interested to see if they learn what
happened to Oliver like either Nyssa or
Merlyn tells them the thing you should
really be getting excited for is Laurel
putting on her Black Canary outfit that
is going to happen in this episode at
some point I think it'll be like a third
act reveal I think they're gonna take a
page from Batman begins with the Laurel
costume arrow does that a lot they're
inspired a lot by the Christopher Nolan
trilogy in the way it told the story
Batman goes out without the cowl no one
is afraid of him so Laurel comes back at
the end of the episode puts her costume
on dyes her hair blonde or gets the
blonde wig and starts trying to scare
the out of people then the next two
or three episodes after that are gonna
be like her Batman year one story she
gets her ass handed to her until she
gets her together to the point
where she can actually catch criminals
without breaking every bone in her body
people have been losing their
about Laurel becoming black Canary's so
quickly but Stephen Amell said to
remember that it's not like she's gonna
put the costume on and automatically be
a superhero we're gonna see her slowly
develop that persona and it's not gonna
just all happen this season like she'll
still be learning stuff next year if you
remember Roy it took him all year to get
the costume and then Nyssa still handed
his ass to him without breaking a sweat
a couple episodes ago so like even Roy
has a long way to go what I'm really
interested to see is if Laurel compels
Wildcat to come back into action to help
them out remember he said he retired
from being a vigilante I just think it'd
be so unfair for the show to tease that
without giving us an actual Justice
Society moment it's like why show us all
of his vigilante gear if he wasn't gonna
be putting it on at some point this
season
moving on to episode 11 so that's called
midnight City I think this is mostly
gonna be a reference to the glades
because it features a couple comic book
characters that we know about
well one potential there might be an
Easter Egg for a comic book character
but Vinnie Jones is gonna debut as brick
or danny brickwell and he'll be
localized in the glades the writer that
wrote this episode also just brought
back dr. midnight in the green arrow
comics so midnight city could be a
reference to dr. midnight he was a big
member of the Justice Society and I know
I keep saying Justice Society and like
most of my arrow videos I do think that
will get at just a society moment before
the end of the year not like an official
like they're not gonna call themselves
just a society it just will get enough
of those characters that you could call
it a Justice Society episode episode 12
is called uprising so this also features
Vinnie Jones again so either he's gonna
be introduced in episode 11 and episode
12 would be a big deal or it'll just be
one big story across two episodes scene
is also coming back to the show and just
for this episode she's not listed on the
cast list for any of the other episodes
this season and everyone's wondering
where she went after the end of season 2
hopefully they'll explain why she lost
touch with Roy or maybe they have been
talking the uprising title could be a
reference to Diggle and Lyla taking
control of Argus the actors did say they
would be taking control of Argus from
Amanda Waller this season
they didn't say why only that Waller was
gonna have other priorities that could
be one of the side effects of The
Suicide Squad movie but they might also
use it as an opportunity for Amanda
Waller on the show to create a new team
like outsiders or something else like
that something to tee up for season four
it's actually also worth noting that
danny brickwell the vinnie jones
character appeared on Oliver's list in
season 1 so nicely straight for the list
moving along episode 13 is called
Canaries I don't think there's any
confusion about what this episode is
gonna be about but part of it will be
dedicated to a flashback scene with Katy
lots like she's coming back to the show
it'll tell a story of how she joined the
League of Assassins I think in present
day we'll also see a lot of Laurel black
Canary's stuff too
interesting to note Masayo said that he
joined the league at the same time as
Sarah so he's probably going to be in
those flashback scenes - episode 14 is
gonna make everyone lose their it
is called the return and will feature
Manu Bennett
that's right Slade is coming back we
don't know if it's gonna be in a
flashback or if it'll be in present-day
and Marc Guggenheim was very clear that
the return the title was not a reference
to Slade returning or a reference to all
of our returning so either someone or
something else really big is returning
but also in that episode Marc singer of
Beastmaster Fame Marc singer the
Beastmaster will be playing Matthew
Shrieve from the comics he's confirmed
as a flashback character as part of like
a big flashback arc in the comics he's
the head of creature commandos
it's a US military team of supernatural
creatures with Frankenstein in the new
52 version of the comics they work for
shade and Frankenstein as the leader so
it's just a small difference but I don't
think we're gonna be seeing Frankenstein
anytime soon in the show just be sure to
look out for Easter eggs usually when
they have something crazy that they're
never gonna do on TV they turn it into
an Easter Egg episode 15 is called Nanda
Parbat that's actually one of my most
anticipated episodes we don't know
anything official about the episode
other than it takes place in Nanda
Parbat but I'm really hoping we get is
Oliver in Nanda Parbat in present-day
but we could also see a team arrow
member roadtrip out there to try and
bring him back after that there's still
seven more episodes including the finale
so there is still like a whole lot of
stuff there's like a whole arc they
could do after all those episodes just
address a few other big things that I
didn't mention in the video yes I do
think that Ray Palmer will be fighting
with team arrow before the end of the
season yes I do think that Oliver will
be back in present day before the last
couple of episodes and no I don't think
that the DJ is Joe Slade's son I think
he's gonna be a big part of the new
but I don't think that he's playing
Deathstroke son because there's so much
legend of course stuff happening tonight
I'm not gonna do a Q&A for this video so
just leave all your questions in the
comments and I'll try to get to them
I am doing a live Q&A for Legend of
Korra tomorrow on my twitch channel it's
probably gonna be in the afternoon I'll
announce when that is whenever I post my
review of the Korra finale so be sure to
subscribe to get that it's gonna be the
last Legend of Korra on TV ever I mean
though they are reruns but it'll be the
last new Korra right now if you're on
your mobile phone or on your tablet
there's new mobile links you can click
on up here it's the same as the links
over here but click here to learn all
about the flash rogues that we're gonna
meet in the second half of the season
and click here to learn all about Rachel
Ghul thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I will see you guys
tonight
you